we've used number lines like all the way
back from like what u 2 u 3 to be able
to do addition and subtraction addition
and subtraction they mean like moving to
the right or moving to the left which
one am i doing which way am I going will
you see this moving to the left right
your numbers are getting smaller so I'm
going to put in one and three quarters
on a pretty one and three question let's
see here if that's one and that's too
where would you put one in three
quarters doesn't just before the two I
think that's a great idea one and three
quarters ok now I'm going to put a
couple of the marks on here as well here
here now when you see that say take away
five take away five you told me to go to
the left right I'm gonna go that many
steps is that ok they're just watch with
me just watch when I do one set just
take away one move to the left one where
do I end up where am i what is this if i
were to label it yeah either there's
three quarters right because you took
one away so now it's three quarters yeah
I'm actually gonna label that frequented
ok now look again what if I went one
more step this is a bit weird because
I've now passed 0 so what's to the left
of here or what are these numbers call
their negative numbers right what is
this negative number toileting now it is
negative where where we are talking in
quarters right but just a look at this
maybe if you can zoom in a little bit
right can you see when I left over here
when I left backwards I left one point
two quarters 3-pointers four quarters
that's one at four quarters is one you
see that so long one two three and I'm
one of these little leaves to the left
each little leave is how much to go on
right so this is not nearly a three
quarter
it's only negative on negative 1 cor you
see that so I'll subtracted 1 i
subtracted 2 I can go again a third time
a fourth time at a fifth time have a
look at the numbers no sixth time I've
gone there 0 there's negative 1 there's
negative 2 what's this number here in
the red number what's that red spot
there it's going to be negative 3
negative 3 and the number i actually
want the place where i am now is just
after it what is that spot negative
three and a quarter whoa so that's a
little trickier we haven't really worked
very much with negative numbers and
fractions so this stuff hard question so
that's why I made it the last one so
well done if you got out number lines
super super help but we don't do them
because we just like lines don't you
like line we do them because these